- It's been a few, (laughs)
a few years since we've
seen each other, right?
- It has been a few years.
I can't see you at all.
I see a big white screen
that says Kelly Clarkson.
- Wow, you're missing out
because I look hot.
I look so good right now.
(audience laughs)
You are missing-
- Is there any way on my Zoom land I can-
- You should promptly
figure it out, Neil
- There you are!
- Yeah, exactly.
- Oh my gosh! What?
- You're welcome.
- You are living in your pink greatness.
- Yes, with someone else's hair, Neil,
but it's fine.
(audience laughs)
- I almost wore that.
- (laughs) You'd probably
look better, you jerk.
So wait, I actually just
celebrated 18 years since "Idol,"
and it made me think of you
because I remember you telling me,
'cause somebody was talking
about "A Moment Like This,"
that people use it for weddings a lot,
and I was like, I remember Neil telling me
that was that y'all's dance?
Was that the song that you?
- That was our first dance song.
That was our song, Kelly Clarkson!
- I love it!
- We don't have
many people in our lives that we talk
like 13-year-old school girls about.
(Kelly laughs)
And you are one of them,
and that song, we met during,
I think, season two of "American Idol"
when it was still this giant juggernaut.
And I think that your song,
that song was playing a lot
and was still connected with.
And so we were falling in
love at that same time,
and the lyrics to that song
always kind of stayed with us.
And we always said if we ever got married,
that would be a great first dance song,
especially with two guys.
Some people wait a lifetime
for a moment like this.
Some people search forever
for that one special kiss.
It was so perfect.
And our parents were there
and we got to dance with them.
- Oh my god, I love your smile.
You're like reliving it.
- And it was to your voice.
(Kelly laughs)